tonight we want to tell you about the
chance to help out kids and their
families right here in the valley this
holiday season
julie danner and her husband jim began a
facebook group a group in march the goal
help families not go hungry as the
pandemic was gaining ground
but the group kept growing both with
volunteers and people needing assistance
over thanksgiving julie's group fed
hundreds of vegas families thanks to
generous donations
now they want to make sure christmas is
just as special and the need has tripled
since thanksgiving
we have all these parents and all these
kids out there that are
um you know in such a tough spot
this year because of everything you know
covet and
and all the shutdowns and you know
either they have gotten covert or
they've gotten injured and they can't go
to work right now or
whatever the story might be and there's
a lot of stories
you know christmas is about magic
here are some numbers the danners are
looking for 3 000
toys to give to kids also they could use
money to buy hams and fixings for
christmas dinner
there are opportunities to help in both
the toy drive and the food drive
to find out how head to 8newsnow.com